Monday edition of PFT p.m. it's supposed
to be a slow day in a slow week it's the
Monday app for the fourth of July
weekend but plenty of things happening
in the NFL and the biggest news came out
of nowhere
Monday afternoon the new contract
between the Kansas City Chiefs and
quarterback Patrick Muhammad as reported
by Adam Schefter ESPN that deal runs
through 2031 that is one of the longest
term deals I have ever seen and I have a
lot of questions about why Patrick
Holmes would commit for that long think
about what can happen in a decade when
you're talking about a player on a given
team the team could be sold who knows
you can't rule that out
you will definitely well I want to say
definitely but most likely have a new
coach by 2031
most likely a new GM by 2031 a lot of
things will be different by then do you
want to have no exit strategy do you
want to have no off-ramp do you want to
be tied to the team beyond the point
where the team is tied you and remember
the team is only tied to you as it
relates to the years that are fully
guaranteed after that you are tied to
the team for as long as the team wants
to keep you and once the guaranteed
money is exhausted in any contract in
the NFL the years after that are
basically one year at a time options
held by the team and as long as they
think it's a good deal for them to keep
paying you what they're supposed to pay
you
they'll keep paying you that amount if
they think it's too much that's when
they rip it up that's why in this case
it's way too long for Patrick and Holmes
to come in unless and this is a big
unless and this is something a lot of
people I suspect are trying to chase
right now and maybe by the time you see
this video well have an answer so I
apologize in advance if this video
quickly becomes obsolete by the news
crush that is going to happen in the
aftermath of the news of this new
contract but the only thing that causes
the mahomes deal to make sense for that
long is if he's the first player in
league history to get a commitment that
he will earn a percentage of the salary
cap because the cap is going to keep
going up and up and up and I know what
you're thinking next year it may not
well that's why what you do
is you pick a certain salary and you
have a percentage of the salary cap in
each year whichever one is greater is
what the player will get that's what
Patrick mahomes needs to have if he's
going to be committed for that long
I like to think that he got that kind of
a commitment before he made that kind of
a commitment but we'll see if if not
it's going to be in my mind a very very
disappointing outcome because whatever
the numbers are and they're gonna be
huge right ten-year extension 400
million dollar contract gigantic forty
million a year that's been the number
we've all been pegging but forty million
a year isn't gonna be that big of a
number five years from now seven years
from now that was the problem with deals
that the Eagles used to do when Joe
banner was the team president the Eagles
would identify their talented core
players early and signed them to ultra
long term deals and inevitably those
players would end up pissed off about
the terms of those deals and the heels
like hey hey hey you took the guaranteed
money you took the signing bonus you
signed the contract a deal's a deal now
I don't know the Chiefs would do that
with Pat mahomes and Pat Roberts doesn't
seem like the type who's going to get
agitated that way but there's a chance
he left a lot on the table if he didn't
get a commitment they'd he'll get
sixteen seventeen eighteen percent of
the salary cap whatever the cap is in
any given year that's the key detail and
here's hoping for his sake that that is
what will happen here's hoping for his
sake and every other NFL players say and
every coach's sake and every executives
sake that this week the NFL and the NFL
PA come together and get a deal done on
what training camp will look like what
the preseason if there is one will look
like well the regular season will look
like and what we've got a variety of
stories that were posted over the
weekend from a document that I obtained
that shows what the NFL PA wants on a
bunch of different issues no mandatory
host of hotel stays during training camp
no 11 on 11 activities on the practice
field at any time all year testing on a
daily basis when training camp starts
with the possibility of reevaluating
later if there aren't a lot are false
negatives and false negatives as big
concerns no meetings of any kind in the
teen facility all meetings occurring
virtually basically you're gonna show up
at the facility get ready for practice
go practice come back change and get the
hell out of it the meetings will all
happen at home like they have been the
entire offseason these are all things
that the players want also no preseason
games of any kind now here's where it
becomes difficult to discern what the
players really want and what is just
leverage for bargaining purposes because
if there are two things you want you
need to ask for for and roulette on two
so both sides feel like they're getting
a bargain so chances are the union
really doesn't want all those things
they've just thrown them some things in
there so they can make concessions and
get the things they really want I just
don't know what they really want and
here's the other thing to keep in mind
you know the NFL doesn't really have to
be doing this the NFL wants to be a good
partner with the players the NFL wants
to have good PR the NFL knows it would
come off as heavy-handed if it just said
the players these are the rules
tough deal with it then you got to worry
about the players poking holes and
complaining in the union poking holes
and complaining and in theory you have
to worry about an argument that the
workplace is sufficiently unsafe to
justify what they call a wildcat strike
where the players just walk off the job
and there have been wildcat strikes
throughout the country during the
pandemic people who have union contracts
who haven't felt safe and said I'm out
of here now when you're talking about
NFL players you're talking about high
stakes poker because if it ends up being
an illegal wildcat strike the damages
become astronomical fairly quickly and
the Union and the players would have to
pay so I don't know that it ever comes
that and here's the other reality the
players proved in 1987 they can't make a
strike stick if some guys walk off honey
you guys aren't gonna walk off and for
every guy who does walk off what's gonna
happen there's gonna be some other guy
out there who gladly takes his place
so I I guess my point is this when push
comes to shove the NFL is going to say
these are the rules and if there's an
impasse there's not going to be some
arbitration or mediation or or
there's an impact on these points if for
example the NFL is bound and determined
to play two preseason games even if the
union is saying no way in hell no
preseason games this year the NFL just
has to say look guys you've already
agreed to the CBA
you've already done it you agreed to the
labor deal during the pandemic okay
we're going forward these are the rules
we're exercising our prerogative under
the CBA to reduce the preseason from
four games to two we can do that we can
reduce it to two without your permission
we're playing two you want zero
too bad you probably want zero every
year too bad you want no 11 on 11
activities practice too bad okay we
won't we can only give you so much
before we get to the point where we
can't get our teams ready so keep an eye
on that because the NFL is trying to
create the perception that is
cooperating with the players and
empowering the players to shape these
rules because they need the players
buy-in you need the players to feel like
their response for these protocols so
they will follow them see it all falls
apart if the players don't do everything
they're supposed to do in the facility
and away from the facility that's why
the NFL is doing but if push comes to
shove the NFL is the one with the power
to do the pushing and the shovel and
meanwhile the coaches and the general
managers are completely and totally in
the dark we've posted something over the
weekend with quotes from unnamed coach
and unnamed GM and obviously it's a
sensitive situation nobody's going to go
on the record with this but they're
upset they don't know what's going on
what if the rule is gonna be the coach
said hey they just expect us to
immediately have a plan for dealing with
whatever they tell us the rules are
going to be even if there's no advance
notice we need to have an opportunity to
figure out what we're going to do so we
need to know what the rules are as soon
as possible same thing for the general
managers they need to know what the
rules are everybody needs to know what
the rules are so they can prepare for
what is coming otherwise it's going to
be potentially chaos for some of these
teams now you know there may be other
teams that look at it and say hey
whatever it is we'll figure it out I
mean do you think Bill Belichick is
sweating any of this
you tell him on a on a Friday at noon
what the rules are gonna be for training
camp starting Monday for example and by
five o'clock on Friday he'll have a bye
full of information and strategy and
planning and he'll be ready to go
whatever the rules are he'll figure out
how to comply and he'll figure out how
to take advantage not a bad way but
he'll find it's like you know it's like
when you play a board game
remember board games anyone or games the
rules were on the inside of the cover
when you open it up and yeah here are
the rules
so if you want to win the game sometimes
you have an aggressive interpretation of
the rules and that's what the ballot
check does he reads the inside of the
cover of the board game and he figures
out what the rules are and then he
figures out how he can use the rules to
his advantage and that's what he'll do
so I think this chaos actually helps a
guy like Bill Belichick so he's probably
enjoying all of this needless to say
he's not the coach that that spoke to me
on an anonymous basis over the weekend
but the bottom line is coaches GM's in
the dark they want to know what's going
on everyone wants to know what's gonna
be going on with testing testing is such
an important aspect of this and right
now we don't know how good the testings
going to be look what baseball is going
through three days to get a result back
on a test it's gotta be faster than that
if it's gonna work in football and again
the players want testing every day they
want saliva testing they want testing
every day that concerned about false
negatives you can't have testing and
then let the guy in and then pluck him
out if it turns out he was positive
that's not how it works you got to keep
him out until you know that he's
negative
and he gotta be damn sure it's not a
false negative all it takes is one false
negative one person we slipped through
the cracks and gets into the facility
and gets out onto the field during a
practice or during a game I mean this is
why the players don't want 11 on 11
practice activities because there is a
chance you're gonna have somebody out
there on the practice field who is
positive now it's unavoidable in a game
setting but the key is going to be
testing efficient reliable and plentiful
testing and if you don't have that
that's one of
that could cause this whole experiment
to fall apart it's combination of
testing and it's combination of players
doing the right things when they aren't
at the facility I'll talk more about
that tomorrow but those are the two key
ingredients testing and responsible
action by the players both in the
facility and out of the facility
all right big story over the weekend if
you were following me as a PFT it just
felt like one domino after another was
falling it started on Friday with the
stunning announcement by the Washington
franchise that they will undertake a
thorough review of their name which
quickly became obvious the name will
change possibly by the start of the 2020
season and then came the Washington Post
interview of Ron Rivera the coach in
Washington who's made it clear he wants
to name the change he's got a couple of
names that he likes he's working with
owner Daniel Snyder Snyder out of a
country keeping a very tight nucleus of
advisors none of whom worked for the
team it feels like he's alienated from
the process but at this point with FedEx
speaking out with Nike speaking out with
Nike taking all Austin gear off of its
website and now with other companies
like Dick's and Target and Walmart not
selling any current Washington gear now
I thought there would be a run on the
stuff containing the name that's about
to go away all the fans of the team that
like that name they want to go snatch
that gear up because they want to have
it they want to wear it they want to
continue to represent the team with the
name that's going away it may be harder
and harder to find anybody that has some
you may want to check eBay because there
may be some jerseys and hats and jackets
and stuff bearing that name that is
selling for a pretty penny now and into
the future
once that name changes and I think the
closer the name is to something that
honors as Ron Barrow wants to do Native
Americans the more relevant the outdated
name will be that's what you can make
the argument a complete break from
anything having any relevance to Native
Americans to make that name even more
meaningless
that year even more meaningless if you
have done a hard turn in a 180 and it's
something that has nothing to do with
Native Americans and as I've been saying
and writing at PFT
I think the National Congress of
American Indians and other
representative groups need to have a
seat at the table they need to be
consulted as to whether or not they even
want to continue to be associated
without franchise it's possible their
attitude is screw you guys frankly we've
been trying to get you to do the right
thing for years and now only after you
get significant economic pressure from a
couple of your sponsors do you decide to
move forward FedEx was founded by Fred
Smith he is one of the minority owners
of the Washington franchise Robert
Rothman Dwight Schar are the others
Sundays news and we broke this as it
relates to Smith and char they have been
trying to sell their interest and this
isn't something new the way that the
Post reported it was char and Smith and
they added Rothman to the mix it creates
the impression that it's something
recent that it's something new my
understanding is they've been trying for
a while
unsuccessfully to sell their interest in
the team and the reason they're
struggling you don't any say you own a
piece of the team but you've got no
power you've got a defer to Dan your
Schneider on everything and you know
really rich people don't like to be in a
position like that so the people who may
be in a position to buy a chunk of the
team at a valuation of three billion
dollars which means if you've got 5%
when my math is gonna fall apart here
quickly what does that work out to 1% of
3 billion would be 30 million right so
5% would be 150 million do you want to
write that kind of a check for something
that you would have no say over no power
over and maybe based on everything
you've heard about the Anderson Eider
he's just not the kind of guy you want
to be doing business with according to
proposed that's why shark and Smith and
Rothman want out they're done with
Daniel Snyder and it creates an
interesting dynamic because I wouldn't
be shocked if as the indignity settles
in for Daniel Snyder the billionaire
who's used to always getting his way
having to change his name of the team
after he came out and said in 20
13 he will never put that in all caps
never change the name he may just decide
I'm gonna cash out sell it to Jeff Bezos
sell it sell the 60% he owns and maybe
the other 40% that the minority owners
hold just sell it all to B's us and let
him take the thing over and I don't
think the league would be upset about
the guy who runs Amazon being one of
their partners as they try to figure out
long-term streaming deals you know it's
one thing to do a deal with Visa this
when he's not one of the owners to one
of the teams it's a very different
dynamic when he's one of the people who
is actually at the table with you as
you're trying to figure out what these
contracts are going to be so let's keep
an eye on what happens with these
minority owners they may sell and get
out of it and someone else comes in as a
partner for Daniel Snyder or maybe
Snyder gets out and they stay or
everybody gets out and somebody comes in
and buys 100% of the franchise moving
forward last thing for today and this
obviously isn't relevant the football
but it is to Cleveland Indy
that's when Friday came out they were
looking at their name and on Sunday
manager Terry Francona said the time has
come to change the name now look it's
not a slur so I don't have a problem
with Indians I don't have a problem with
Chiefs it was very easy to say the
Washington name has to go because it's a
dictionary to find slur it gets more
complicated analysis and it's really up
to the teams and hey they want to
consult with Native American
representative groups they want to
consider their alternatives you know for
some teams it's it's a it's a nice nice
boosting of the brand if you have a new
name now the Chiefs I don't you know
they're they're the at the pinnacle
right now I just wonder if the Indians
changed their name at what point the
Chiefs just at least have the
conversation and and I'm not saying that
anyone other than Washington needs to
change their name the Edmonton Eskimos
recently decided after deliberating and
thinking about it consciously wondering
whether or not they should change their
name CFL franchise decided they're
keeping their name
maybe the Indians will ultimately decide
to keep internet maybe the Chiefs will
decide to keep theirs if they at least
engage in a conscientious review of
whether they should keep it I just think
in this moment it makes sense to take a
step back and recalibrate and
reconfigure and reevaluate the name and
maybe you decide it's fine and that's
fine if you do I got no problem with it
it's not a slur
now the headdresses I think you need to
rethink some of that the
misappropriation of the culture but
those can be problematic and also hey
anyone that has a problem with
disrespect to the national anthem when
it's done for strategic reasons the the
shouting in unison of Chiefs in place of
the last word of the national anthem
kind of disrespectful to be anthem so
there are some things that maybe the
organization of the fan base should take
a closer look at but that is the
decision that's got to be made by the
franchise's it's not nearly the
no-brainer that that the Washington name
was and look how long it took to change
the one that was a no-brainer so an
issue that isn't going away because the
Indians are looking at their name I'll
be interests to see if the Chiefs end up
looking
at their name as well alright that's it
for today's PFT p.m. we'll continue to
do this until PFT live returns two weeks
from today on July 20 but every day a
rundown everything that's happening in
the NFL and plenty of things are
happening is we get closer and closer to
training camp remember next week the
franchise tag deadline is coming for
long-term deals that Prescott Chris
Jones and others either will or won't do
no new deals so plenty of reasons to
stay tuned to pro football talk comm
check us out every day from PFT p.m.
have a great Monday see you back here on
Tuesday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports